as people get ready to return to the
beach this summer they may encounter a
hidden danger
rip currents are the reason for about 80
percent of lifeguard rescues
every year they can be deadly and hard
to spot
but scientists at noaa's national ocean
service have a new way to keep people
safe
they've developed a model to predict rip
currents days before they
form in ocean waters christina raffini
traveled to kill devil hills
north carolina to talk to scientists and
lifeguards
who work together to create this
life-saving tool
the biggest danger to swimmers at this
north carolina beach
lurks just under its cold foamy water
you won't see it unless you know what
you're looking for and it doesn't have
fins or teeth we estimate that rip
currents lead to
about a hundred drownings per year
across the u.s
and so they're the number one public
safety risk at the beach
greg dusic is with the national oceanic
and atmospheric administration
he spends a lot of time studying waves
and
keeping up with current events for
people who don't know what is a rip
current rip currents
are like rivers of water that flow from
near the beach
offshore and they can occur anywhere you
have breaking waves
even in shallow water they can be a
serious hazard to both beachgoers
and camera gear years ago 64 people
in an hour and a half pulled out of rip
currents in a five mile section in one
day
no in a five mile section of beach just
my town david elder runs the ocean
rescue squad in kill devil hills north
carolina
the team ran us through a simulated
rescue drill
in a strong rip current that formed the
day we visited
just a few feet off this beach the
reason people don't understand rip
currents is because they can't model
what's going on out here
you've explained it to me like three
times and i gotta tell you i still can't
see the difference we try to create the
context
through discussion first and then by
actually
showing people physical rip currents
to explain how it works in this video
ocean safe green dye
is used to show how fast the rip
currents can pull unsuspecting swimmers
out to sea
about 10 years ago elder and other
lifeguard groups started sharing their
on-the-job observations with dusic
he combined their knowledge with
cutting-edge technology and came up with
this
the world's first computer model that
can predict rip currents
like a weather forecast up to six days
in advance
what noaa is trying to do is get people
more information so that you're ready
for
what hazards to expect at the beach
before you set your feet in the sand
and if you do find yourself being pulled
away from shore
the key is not to panic but it's easier
said than done
even only standing in it up to my knees
okay right okay like even right now i'm
more relaxed than you and it's just
and the thing is this you can't fight
mother nature so don't try i need you to
relax and work with me
and just feel it try to swim parallel to
the shoreline
or find a flotation device and always
pick a beach
with lifeguards the ocean is an
inherently unsafe environment
it is not here to kill you it is here
for you to pay attention to
that means paying attention to the waves
and checking the rip current forecast
before you hit the boardwalk
talk to lifeguard ask them about today's
beach what's going on
what's happening in the water that way
everyone can walk away safe
from their day at the beach for cbs this
morning saturday christina raffini kill
devil hills north carolina
have either of you been caught in
riptides
i know people who have been impacted
their lives changed forever and families
have been changed forever by what's
happened in rip
currents and they are a big deal and
important to learn about and one of the
challenges is educating kids so they
understand
because you can't it's so difficult to
see and kids don't understand like if
you're being swept out like what you're
supposed to do
yeah i think it's really amazing though
this technology you think of like shark
warnings you know
sharks have been cited in the water
jellyfish warnings whatever those are if
there's a way to mark this
just to warn people who are going out in
the water that day
be helpful some